welcome back to new rock stars i'm eric
boss and marvel's eternals now has a
full trailer for us to look at to figure
out what the hell is going on in this
movie that looks nothing like a marvel
movie and maybe that's a good thing so
i'm gonna watch and react to this
then give you my first thoughts and i'm
gonna break down who everyone is and
where the hell they've been all this
time they better have a good reason to
sit out of infinity war i'm just saying
and after i get my first thoughts i will
have
my full in-depth brain by frame
breakdown of this probably sometime
tomorrow
so let's give this a watch a watch and
hear me
go
i like this song
[Music]
it's beautiful listening
okay now we're getting the good stuff
wow
we have watched
[Music]
unguided we have helped them
progress sometimes
unseen accomplish
wonders and let half of it all dust away
throughout the years oh good a rumple of
[ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
there they are
[Music]
thank you for this oh you are so now
that captain rogers and iron man are
both gone
who do you think's gonna lead the
avengers
i could lead them yeah okay
yeah okay icarus you're gonna leave the
avengers after not
interfering with the mad titan thanos
dusting half of them away and the other
time he came back
or you know when uh ultron traumatized
everyone or when loki invaded earth with
the chitauri army
or when goo attacked mizura that was a
big one none of people talk about that
that dairy queen is dunzo
now in fairness to the eternals a lot of
those attacks were real sudden
also they may have been helping out in
those battles in ways we didn't see the
way that we saw the ancient one in the
battle of new york during an end game
just fighting on a different front maybe
the camera just wasn't pointing at them
yet i also like the theory that
maybe in the past sometimes sprite wiped
all their memories so in the modern era
maybe they haven't
realized that they're these powerful
beings with the ability to help out in
these battles but already you see i am
making some excuses for these guys so
just to give a sense of who everyone is
the eternals are kind of these ageless
god-like beings who have existed on
earth for thousands of years just kind
of hanging out in the background helping
out in various little ways like helping
mankind progress with uh basic
agricultural technology they were
created by the celestials who are the
true gods of the marvel universe
giant massive armored beings that we saw
in the guardians of the galaxy but we
have not yet seen in this trailer i
assume they're gonna save those for the
second trailer maybe
interesting to note that thanos is part
of that same lineage he is a celestial
but has a deviant gene
making him considered a deviant the
deviants are another race of beings who
are
eternally at war with the eternals but
before i continue
you've probably heard us talk about
helix mattresses right how great they
are
how they're selected to fit your
specific sleep needs yadda yadda well
our friends at helix have started making
sofas
they've launched a new company called
all form and they're making awesome
furniture all form lets you customize
the sofa using premium materials at a
fraction of the cost of traditional
stores you pick a fabric the color of
the legs sofa size
and then shape to fit you and your home
they've got everything from armchairs to
eight-seat sectionals which are great
for having a bunch of people over for a
movie night or
for sitting really far away from one of
the person who doesn't share your taste
in netflix shows actually new rockstars
editor
john has an armchair and an ottoman from
all form
and he loves them he customize it in
brown leather so
now he is lounging in style and that
could be you that's a nice chair
all four of sofas are delivered directly
to your home with fast free shipping
they'll get you your custom furniture in
just three to seven days
and you can assemble it yourself in a
few minutes no tools needed you get 100
days to decide if you want to keep it
and if you don't love it they'll pick it
up for free and give you a full refund
they even offer a forever
warranty literally forever
so to find your perfect sofa check out
allform.com
new rockstars and all form is offering
20 off all orders for
our audience at allform.com new
rockstars so in this group you have
gemma chan playing
cersei she's really the lead of this
film and she's been kind of
in love with icarus richard madden's
character who's kind of the leader of
the eternals
though it looks like there's going to be
a love triangle as she starts to fall
for
dane whitman aka the black knight who
wields the ebony blade he is
human which is interesting to see rob
stark and jon snow in kind of a love
triangle there there
is that fun line from game of thrones
where he said next time i see you you'll
be all in black and those characters
never met again so now he is seeing jon
snow as
the black knight which is fun camille
nanjiani is playing kingo who is keeping
a low profile
as a major bollywood star liam mchugh is
playing sprite who appears as a 12 year
old girl but is capable of creating
these illusions in people's minds brian
tyree henry is playing fastos
he is a brilliant engineer who helps
humans with technology
he's going to be the first superhero
depicted as gay in an mcu film lauren
ridloff is playing makari she
is a deaf actress playing the first deaf
superhero and she can move at super
speeds
which you get a little taste of as she's
like flipping through that book real
fast soma hayek is playing ajax who's
kind of the spiritual leader of the
eternals with special healing powers and
she has a direct link with the
celestials don lee is playing gilgamesh
who's the strongest of the eternals
angelina jolie is playing fina who's the
military leader of the eternals and then
our possible villain of this story is
barry kyoen i'm sorry if i mispronounced
that in the past or if i mispronounced
it now he's playing druid who's kind of
a detached eternal for the rest of the
group he can use his cosmic energy to
control the minds of others
and as i pointed out in our teaser
breakdown like a month ago he really
does appear to have set up this kind of
cult in the woods where he is
controlling these people
because he believes humanity is
benefiting too much from eternal
interference
with technology medical technology that
kind of thing
maybe he set up this kind of a woodland
sanctuary where technology and human
advancements don't affect their
lifestyle so this interesting song
choice of skeeter davis is the end of
the world here
it's a classic breakup song but also has
this exaggeration to it how when you go
through a breakup it feels like
everything is apocalyptic that another
day won't begin after this
was just a nice reflections plot it's a
romantic plot between
cersei and dane whitman and icarus but
also comes from this point of view of
someone who says
don't these eternals know it's the end
of the world why haven't they come to
help us
this interesting conversation at the end
i guess this is the eternal shawarma
meal here where sprite says now that
iron man and captain rogers are gone
right so again we're getting to tease
that steve rogers isn't hiding somewhere
in this universe even though we got
those jokes in the falcon of the winter
soldier that he was on the moon
but i guess it is still possible that he
could be on some secret moon base set up
by nick fury also marvel comics the
group on the moon is supposed to be the
inhumans who are derived from the
eternals i don't think that's where
captain rogers is though yeah confirm
that we are seeing the ishtar gate of
babylon the ancient city there
now pieces of it are in museums but it
was originally in modern day iraq
so this plot is going to be jumping
around at different points in history
where you see the eternals who either
choose to get involved or stay
out of certain conflicts to help
whatever society of all
and based off of the relics and makari's
room here that's going to include
some pieces of medieval history in
europe ancient egyptian history
there's a shot of sprite with some kind
of armor plate on her chest with symbols
that you know i'm gonna try to translate
in the breakdown so stay tuned for that
behind her the landscape is covered in
lava which might come from this big
volcano eruption now we did
see the volcano of mount vesuvius erupt
and destroy pompei in the loki trailer
we know loki's gonna be revisiting that
this does not look like the same volcano
though to be fair the footage of that
volcano and loki they actually
took some photography from mount st
helen's eruption we don't really know
what vesuvius looked like when it
exploded because
we weren't fair they didn't have cameras
back then but this could just be another
example of sprite unable to save a group
of people some civilization that
got destroyed by this volcano and this
is just an example of some natural
disaster
that sometimes it's an act of god that
takes people out
but now what we used to consider to be
acts of god are acts of these gods in
action
which is an interesting conversation to
have for sure yeah i'm really glad they
included this scene at the end of the
trailer with
the discussion of how they look at the
avengers is the absence of the avengers
now what caused them
finally to decide to intervene i don't
think so i think there's going to be
some bigger crisis
because like the avengers weren't around
before 2008 the avengers broke up after
civil war
yeah some bigger crisis whether that is
a new big bad arriving in the mcu i
theorized that maybe after someone like
thanos arrived to earth and
psychologically scarred
everyone on that planet they might start
looking into who this guy was and
realize that he was
an eternal with a deviant gene started
asking a lot of questions about
ancient genetic history and earth's
actual history with all these cosmic
forces
creating a debate between people with
normal dna and people who might have an
interesting type of anomaly in their dna
what something we might eventually call
the mutant gene or the x gene which all
ties into that celestial history now do
i think wolverine's going to show up in
this movie
no i don't think so but i do think it
might start giving us a language of how
people with different types of genetic
history exist in the mcu
and a couple years from now marvel may
say hey that's how we ended up with
mutants in this universe anyway that's
all i got for right now but i want to go
back through this frame by frame to find
every other easter egg hidden in here
but let me know your thoughts on this
trailer in the comments below be sure to
subscribe to new rockstars for
breakdowns of everything you love follow
me at eavos check out one of our great
merch options at new rockstarsmerch.com
and i'll see you next time bye
[Music]
foreign
[Music]